watching of Valley's most accurate
forecast on 8 news now never get tired
of that holiday show it's the best all
right as we look out over the North
Valley this view yesterday had some
pretty dark ominous clouds and that was
energy coming off the spring mountains
brought some snow up to Lee Canyon for
their opening day up there and some rain
showers across the Northwest and North
Valley neighborhoods it's all gone now
we've got great Sunshine temperatures in
the 50s around the valley we started out
in the very cold 30s this morning wow
was it cold and below normal should have
morning lows for this time in early
December in the low 40s it's still just
freezing in Caliente 28 in Ely at this
hour freezing in totapa 37 in Reno we've
got 45 up the road in Indian Springs 50
for Pahrump 52 in Boulder City 59 in
Laughlin there's just some cold air over
the Great Basin right now in many parts
of the country we'll take a look in a
moment we're kind of under high pressure
weak high pressure it'll be tranquil
quiet weather for a couple of days and
then we've got to focus on the weekend
some occasional clouds we've got
afternoons with sun shine here in the
cool 50s for a couple of days Sunday is
really the focus because that's when a
strong Pacific storm will take aim at
the desert we've got a chance of
widespread Valley rain and some pretty
good Mountain snow Breezy to Gusty winds
too that will focus on a Saturday night
into Sunday could even linger into
Monday so this system right now hitting
the West Coast that will mainly affect
the Northern Great Basin with some
showers snow will hit the Sierra we'll
just get the clouds from it tonight but
it will reinforce the cold moving over
the Rockies the Northern Plains check
out the temperatures up north we're only
talking 20s and some 30s right now but
boy you look in the Southern Plains
Houston's in the 80s 70s for Dallas near
80 for Savannah Georgia still some
showers across the Tennessee Valley into
the Carolinas so we'll sit here with
with dry conditions but we'll get a
taste of these clouds with this system
tonight those should clear out for
Friday with more Sunshine then that next
system is going to be a cold one out of
the Gulf of Alaska that will affect us
as I say mainly on Sunday so if you have
outdoor plans for Sunday you might want
to rethink those move them into Saturday
or maybe make a plan B 56 today 57
tomorrow start seeing some clouds on
Saturday and get some wind and we'll
start to see the slight chances of
showers overnight Saturday better chance
for rain could see maybe up to a quarter
inch of rain in some areas on Sunday and
the snow levels down to about 5000 feet
there is a rush of cold air coming
Sunday night into early Monday that
could mix a little bit of snow with rain
even down to the valley floor John or at
least West Valley neighborhoods we'll
see if that comes to fruition a very
cold week next week with highs in the
upper 40s and Mornings in the 20s that's
way ahead of schedule thank you Sherry